on the hill tonight for the giants will
be
the veteran alex wood alex wood in his
eighth year at the big league level he's
making his 15th start having a good
first half seven and three with the
three eight nine era
81 strikeouts in 76 in the third so here
is edmond
to lead it off for the cardinals
foul and right past third base coach ron
warner oh a kick save out there strike
three call
there's his first slider of the game and
put it right on the outside edge
cardinals get a runner in scoring
position five for nine for nolan in this
series
hits it out to right the cardinals have
the lead goldie will score
coronado racing to second he is
safe at second somehow he avoided the
tag
and it's one nothing cardinals here in
the top of the first
they're gonna review this play now we're
gonna get the call from new york and the
call is safe so the giants use their
challenge
lose their challenge johann oviedo
and still he is looking for that elusive
first
major league win yeah and you can't
focus on it you know it people ask you
about it
in any interview you do wilmer flores
now the giants with two men on and
nobody out
basement to right field over the head of
goldsmith
wade gets the stop sign and he saw it
very late he took a real aggressive turn
bases loaded nobody out great
opportunity here
two and two on alex dickerson the pitch
a swing and a mess he struck him out
dickerson went for the high heat one
gone here's brandon crawford
the 2-2
popped up left side arenado there in
foul territory makes the catch
and now he's one out away from getting
out of this first inning jam
jason fossler look out
and that headed and that is how the
giants
get their first run to tie this game
cassalli at third
niger the infield back normal depth
that ball is hit deep center field
baiter back still going back still going
back hits off the wall cassalli has
scored
yes has a stand up double two to one
giants now oviedo steps off the slab
oviedo's yelling at mike kostremski like
he thinks that
ustremski's relaying signs stratski's
yelling back
at him he's telling you to shut up
steven duggar will lead off against
oviedo
bottom of the fourth and duggar smashes
one
backhanded on one hop by de young and he
throws him out that was a nice play
[Applause]
that's a big league shortstop that ball
was hit hard and he caught it on the
backhand and one pitch one out
casali works a walk alex wood again
situation to potentially bunt aronado is
in on the grass
and goldschmidt holding it first
[Applause]
is down aronado to second and he gets
the lead man
nice pick by the young aggressive play
and it pays off
that's a go good play right there it was
i'm tommy edmond
tommy has been called out on strikes and
grounded out to first to pitch
grounded to short crawford's not going
to go between the legs he does have to
get rid of it quickly
and he got it there in time
that was a heck of a play from brandon
crawford tommy edmond could fly
flores the number three hitter in the
order waddell works from the stretch
from the middle of the pitching rubber
and he throws a strike it's hard hit
diving play up the middle by the second
baseman sosa throws out flores
like every night that mundo sosa is in
the lineup he's doing something he's
doing something either with the glove or
with the bat
this ball is hit really hard to the
backhand side
nice play so now with two men on solano
is going to pinch it here
solano breaks his bat a little looper
and it falls for a base hit
alex dickerson's gonna come around and
score crawford chugging his way to third
and into second with a double donovan
solano makes it three to one giants
that's the biggest swing of the bat
tonight for the gennads alex woods still
in the game pitching well now he's got a
two-run lead this
is the heart of the order though carlson
goldschmidt are in auto for the third
time against wood that's a good test
one two he did right on the corner for
strike three called
brushes across the inside corner
now goldsmith strikes out swinging 93
mile an hour fastball
sit on the inside corner and he's kind
of leaks it out over the middle but
at 93 looks like coachman we have been
thinking about something soft because
that ball was by him
swings here pops it up cassalli
back toward the on deck circle makes a
catch
that's just a great inning for alex
woods mike yostrimsky with the infield
of double play depth
up the middle through his legs to young
across the diamond and got him went
through his legs i believe
and de young off balance with the throw
to get the out
go ahead paul that is not an easy play
momentum
momentum is taking him out into left
field
so tense moments here at oracle park
so the cardinals threatening here
requires the first third one out
goldschmidt with arenado on deck goldie
that makes it 3-2 carpenter will score
carlson stopped at second
and paul goldschmidt cuts the lead
to one 2-1 ground ball
crawford to second one the relay
two a double play arenado bounces into a
double play
and that ends the cardinals rally they
do pick up a run against rogers
now darren ruff who walked in his first
paid appearance
that one is into deep center way back
there
still going
to be a two run homer
for darren ruff
five to two giants
well they set an inside target and look
at the mistake out over the plate
and he clips this with backspin at 105
miles per hour it takes on center field
and it's a mismatch all the young is all
for two with a walk
the young base hit into left this will
be extra bases
and a double for the cardinals shortstop
on base twice tonight with a walk in
that double
so two down andrew kisner the catchers
strike three call
right down the middle and the ball game
is over